on en parlait en début d'émission en
janvier c'est le défi du mois sans
alcool on va en parler avec vous guérez
nous guérino vous êtes médecin et membre
de la Ligue de la Ligue contre le cancer
des Yvelines alors c'est une initiative
qui a été lancée en Grande-Bretagne je
crois et elle est ensuite venue en
France est-ce qu'elle est beaucoup
suivie en France alors elle était lancée
effectivement en Angleterre en 2013 où
les apparemment c'est bien suivi elle
est venue en France je crois en 2018
alors on peut pas dire que le succès
phénoménal enfin il y a 10% des
personnes qui suivent effectivement ce
mois sans alcool et qui apparemment
respecte la procédure on en parle de
plus en plus
oui on en parle de vous savez on a tout
à l'heure qu'il y avait une application
de rail trail que les gens peuvent
consulter apparemment le téléchargement
de cette application augmenter de 15%,
l'année dernière donc quel est
l'objectif de
cette introspection sur soi-même pour se
rendre compte à quel point on peut
consommer au nom de l'alcool
la consommation d'alcool est quand même
extrêmement importante en France on
considère que 43 millions de personnes
qui boivent de l'alcool ça veut pas dire
que 43% d'alcoolique 43 millions
d'alcooliques mais le problème c'est que
il y a 10% des alcooliques qui
consomment 58% de l'alcool consommé en
France donc cela sont vraiment dans dans
très très consommateurs alors c'est pas
forcément cela qui vont être le plus
concernés on parle bon pas s'intéresser
à moins sans alcool par contre les gens
qui ont une consommation un petit peu
au-dessus de ce qu'on conseille si vous
voulez bon probablement effectivement
bénéficier de cette procédure on
considère que au-delà de 3 verres alors
ce sont il s'agit de verres j'en vers
bistrot si vous voulez
au-delà de trois verres par jour on
considère que l'on dépasse on dépasse
déjà la dose conseiller ça c'est pour
les hommes pour les femmes c'est plutôt
dur on sait on conseille un petit peu
moins
pas cette différence entre homme et
femme
la réceptivité pas la même on parlera
peut-être des complications tout à
l'heure mais les complications chez les
femmes ne se mesure directement au
presque au vert près enfin l'idée on
arrive assez facilement
chiffrés si vous voulez le risque
notamment pour les femmes dès le premier
vers mais dès qu'on dépasse la dose
conseillée oui un risque absolument oui
alors quelles sont les complications
justement on peut en parler maintenant
ah bah les complications de l'alcool
elles sont extrêmement nombreuses
on considère que le
ça remplit un peu les hôpitaux on
considère que le coûte de l'alcool de
l'alcool en France et d'environ 120
milliards d'apparence c'est-à-dire 6% du
PIB c'est considérable
l'alcool entraîne des complications en
dehors du cancer on les connaît c'est la
cirrhose du foie c'est
la pancréatite chronique c'est pas tout
un tas de complications et en plus il y
a le cancer alors le cancer par contre
au niveau de l'alcool c'est le cancer
des voies digestives supérieures la
langue
la bouche les orages et là ce sont des
cancers extrêmement graves est-ce que
selon
vous les informer sur sur
ces je crois que les gens qui sont
soumis au risque de plus importants sont
très bien informés quand vous avez les
gens qui consomment par exemple dans un
bistrot
il savent très bien que tel ou tel de
leur copains étaient atteint d'un cancer
qui déborde un cancer enfin les gens les
gens le savent
alors après il peut y probablement ça
c'est les gros consommateurs par contre
les consommateurs moyens c'est pas sûr
c'est pas sûr on doit considérer que
quelques verres par jour c'est pas un
problème en fait si c'est un problème si
on dépasse trois verres par jour on
entre dans le problème à contrario
quelles sont les bénéfices sur sa santé
du coup si on arrête pendant un mois de
consommer de l'alcool ah bah les Anglais
vont bien démontrer ils ont démontré
qu'il y a au début il y a quelques
inconvénients le fait d'arrêter de boire
de l'alcool ça vous rend un peu anxieux
ça vous ça trouve un peu votre sommeil
et puis un risque déshydratation parce
que l'alcool c'est quand même du liquide
et donc si je ne pense pas avec un autre
liquide il peut y avoir un risque
déshydratation alors les Anglais ont
montré que il y avait un bénéfice tout à
fait évident
une fois qu'on a passé ces inconvénients
là on retrouve un sommeil normal on
retrouve une meilleure forme on
la perte de il y a une perte de poids on
récupère un poids normal alors qu'on
avait grossi avec l'alcool et ils ont
montré également que ces bénéfices là se
poursuivent pendant plusieurs semaines
voire plusieurs mois après après le mois
sans alcool donc ça a vraiment des
bénéfiques des effets bénéfiques c'est
ce qu'on appelle la détoxification en
particulier au niveau du foie est-ce que
vous allez tenter de relever le défi
autour du plateau est-ce que vous avez
vous êtes lancé dans ce défi là au mois
de d'arrêter de consommer de l'alcool
Régine je bois déjà très très peu
d'alcool donc j'ai pas ce souci là
me rend gère Philippon moi j'ai de la
chance je n'aime pas ça
donc c'est très facile pour moi en tant
que coach nutrition je suppose que
vraiment j'ai jamais aimé ça et j'ai
jamais essayé donc tant mieux comme
c'est moi qui conduit quand on rentre de
soirée et vous Bruno Broussard
moi je pense en écoutant les chiffres
que hormis les périodes de fait
quelqu'un boit ma part d'accord
et est-ce que du coup il y avait il y a
des outils mis en place pour justement
motiver les personnes à continuer à
arrêter de consommer de l'alcool pendant
ce mois de janvier et les mois suivants
ce que vous mettez en place des
initiatives des au niveau de la Ligue
non puisque nous ce essentiellement
tourne autour du cancer pas de pas de
l'alcool mais je pense qu'effectivement
c'est le rôle des généralistes quand
même de d'accompagner leur client ils
les connaissent mieux que n'importe qui
et ils savent très bien comment manager
le ce retour si vous voulez une à une
hygiène normale
si on veut sortir de cette addiction il
faut plutôt se tourner vers son médecin
alors les généralistes au début si
l'addiction est trop importante il
faudra avoir à faire vraiment des
addictologues non c'est vraiment le
c'est difficile c'est très difficile et
bien merci beaucoup d'avoir accepté
notre invitation et si vous souhaitez
avoir plus de renseignements n'hésitez
pas à vous rendre sur le site internet
qui s'affiche en bas de l'écran